easter eggs are usually fun sidebar
references visual gags or inside jokes
that directors put in movies
as a reward for eagle-eyed viewers but
some filmmakers use them as
opportunities to startle or
outright frighten audiences these movie
easter eggs are so creepy we almost wish
we'd never found them at all
trophy room you don't have to watch the
alien movies to know xenomorphs are bad
news
if something out there is tough enough
to actually exterminate one of these
things
they've gotta be super hardcore and
we're not just talking about ripley
not bad for it human
[Music]
so if predator 2 really wanted to hammer
home how powerful those predators really
are
having them take down a xenomorph would
be a good way to do it well mission
accomplished
just before the film's climactic battle
against the predators
danny glover's character lieutenant mike
harrington comes across a case filled
with various skulls
for about a second the camera shows what
is clearly a xenomorph skull
which is as much proof as any that
predators are not to be messed with
if they can kill some of the most
vicious aliens in the galaxy
steer clear this brief crossover
predated the avp franchise by over a
decade
though the jury's still out on whether
that weight was worth it
ash versus freddie directors sam raimi
and west craven really like to reference
one another
as evidenced by the several maccabees
directs between them
the first came by way of a nightmare on
elm street where nancy is desperate to
stay awake
so she watches evil dead it barely works
and she soon shuts it off in favor of
other methods of staying awake in evil
dead 2
rainey returned the favor by including
several brief shots of freddy krueger's
glove hanging over the door in the shed
where ash gets his chainsaw
hand apparently this reference was so
nice he had to do it twice
in the series ash vs evil dead the glove
appeared again
groovy mid-world pennywise stephen king
loves to pepper his bugs with references
to his other works
he's like pixar but you know if every
horrifying character was said
where are your rebel friends now
the 2017 adaptation of kings the dark
tower series honors this rich tradition
with one of the creepiest easter eggs of
all as jake enters mid-world in the film
he walks through an abandoned carnival
at one point he comes across a statue of
a severed hand holding three balloons
and what creepy stephen king character
loves his balloons
yep that would be pennywise the scariest
clown this side of the sewer system
and just in case you weren't sure above
jake stands a large crumbling sign that
clearly says pennywise
in addition to being pretty freaky this
egg actually makes narrative sense
pennywise can be anything and go
anywhere so why wouldn't he chill in
midworld looking for a meal also
after all they float over there too
overlooked design
for a children's cartoon toy story is
pretty creepy to start with
the idea that toys are alive and
watching their little owners at all
times is a little unsettling and the
filmmakers made things even weirder by
including references to one of the
creepiest films ever the shining
in the first toy story take a look at
the carpet in the upstairs hallway of
sid's house
if the pattern seems familiar it's
because it first appeared in the
overlook hotel in stanley kubrick's
adaptation of the shining
and even freakier the carpet is
prominently featured in a scene when
dany plays with his toys
so not only is sid a psychopathic toy
torturer who probably belongs on a fbi
watch list
he also lives in the house sized version
of the overlook not content with just
making creepy references in one movie
pixar decided to load up toy story 3
with even more
in the control room of the daycare
center the intercom is almost an exact
copy of the one in the overlook
manager's office and the box of tissues
is printed with that carpet design again
the number 237 the number of the haunted
hotel room in the shining also shows up
several times
who's velocistar237 oh
that's just a dinosaur toy down the
street that's nothing let me just take
care of that
the number appears on a security camera
labeled overlook r237
and on the license plate of a garbage
truck either the pixar crew just wants
to creep out kids subconsciously or they
just really like horror movies
an unfortunate cameo gyro captain is one
of the weirder characters in mad max the
road warrior the unhinged the gyrocopter
pilot became the leader of the oil
refinery tribe and led them north at the
end of the movie
never to be heard from again at least
until fiore road
nux's car is a skull on one of its pikes
and not just any skull but the skull of
a pilot with a flight helmet that looks
creepily similar to the gyro captains
the design is a little different but how
many other characters in the mad max
franchise wear flight helmets
if that really is the gyro captain's
head it makes road warriors ending more
bittersweet
because it suggests that the war boys
caught up with the oil refinery tribe
executed their leaders and took them
into the citadel whatever happened to
them
it can't be pretty puppet show
creepy puppets are spine tinglingly
scary when they're done right
although the saw franchise has had its
ups and downs over the years billy the
puppet remains consistently creepy
and he isn't content to spook us in just
one franchise
he keeps showing up in others take for
example dead silence
a movie about evil life-ending dolls
drawing a scene in which the main
characters explore an abandoned theater
there's a brief shot showing billy with
the other paranormal dolls
the whole place is literally a creepy
doll club where they just all hang out
together which makes that the creepiest
theater in existence
but our favorite killer puppet didn't
stop there insidious is on billy's list
of cameos too
early in the movie a rough sketch of
billy shows up on the blackboard in a
classroom
from a different angle you can see
another less creepy easter egg on the
same board
the director's name james wan since juan
directed dead silence
insidious and sore we guess it makes
sense that it includes these easter eggs
even if it creeps the audience out by
implying that billy is following them
into other movies
dr doom when jinn bumped into dr evazan
and ponder baba on jeddah it seemed like
a fun little nod to a new hope
we knew that within a week dr everson
would be threatening luke skywalker in
mos eisley
and ponder baba would be short one arm
for some reason though the production
team
couldn't let this little moment stand as
a simple nod to the original film
they had to create one of the more
disturbing easter eggs in star wars
history in a new hope
dr evazon tells luke that he has a death
sentence in 12 systems but we never
really find out why
rogue one fills in the gaps eagle-eyed
viewers might have noticed that a few
background citizens on jeddah had their
heads cut in half
these poor people are the decraniated a
mysterious doctor named rufu created
them by destroying their brains and
making them as slaves even more
disturbing
the official star wars website confirmed
that rufu is an alias for dr evazan
turning a fun little easter egg into a
part of a full-blown horror story
now we're even happier that obi-wan
dealt with those creeps before they
could mess with luke's brain
norwegian spoiler in the opening scene
of the 1982 version of the thing
american researchers discover a
norwegian crew trying to dispatch a dog
one terrified member of the party is
screaming something at the americans but
there aren't any
subtitles so for all english-speaking
audiences can tell
he's just yelling gibberish brought on
by madness
if you speak norwegian however the movie
immediately becomes even more terrifying
what he's actually saying is get the
hell away it's not a dog it's a thing
it's imitating a dog it's not real
get away idiots but since none of the
american characters are you know fluent
in norwegian they don't understand what
the crazy old man is saying
and we know what happens next a whole
lot of this
it's a creepy little easter egg that
totally changes the story turning the
whole thing into an ironic tragedy
we also feel terrible for that
researcher who tried to help him
only to get shot for his troubles if
only the researchers had brushed up on
their languages they might have survived
x marks the spa from the start of the
departed
it's obvious that most of these
characters won't make out of the movie
alive
but what we didn't expect was for
director martin scorsese to physically
mark every character who wouldn't
yup every character who gets whacked
appears with an x nearby at some point
some are really obvious others not so
much frank costello was marked early in
the movie
with the crossbeams of his tire garage
forming an x
matt damon's character has x's around
him all throughout the movie
even though he doesn't bite the bullet
until the final act but of course
there's a big red x on the carpet right
before he finally does meet his end
dedication to this easter egg reaches
almost comical proportions and near the
end of the movie in the elevator scene
when costa gun stands right next to a
giant tape x
even less subtle are the x's for telling
captain queen and zen
they show up in the windows of the
building that he's falling from
scorsese's little inside joke turns a
cool gangster movie into a super morbid
treasure hunt
swan bones darren aronofsky's black swan
is filled with background imagery from
morphing faces showing true identities
to crazy mirror tricks watch the movie
again knowing all of the visual tricks
and the whole story becomes even more
unsettling but the creepiest easter egg
is found in the ballet director's office
pay attention when nina goes and asks
for a putt
right next to the director's desk is a
model of a swan skeleton in front of one
of the film's many mirrors
an insanely creepy decoration to just
have around in the office
but also an unsettling foreshadowing of
nina's eventual collapse
all throughout the movie aronofsky uses
mirrors to represent nina's fractured
personality
so this little detail couldn't be
anything but a reference to nina's
terrible fate
face off as if psycho didn't have enough
terrifying visuals in it
director alfred hitchcock made sure to
sneak in one more at the end
just for good measure not content with
scaring the audience consciously
he also wanted to get under their skin
specifically with the final shot of
norman bates
why she wouldn't even have a fly
[Music]
that's actually one frame of norman's
face merged with the corpse of his
mother
not only is it terrifying it shows that
norman's mother is now in complete
control of his persona
hitchcock didn't want any subtlety about
how norman turns out
and this frame was his way of showing
one last time how messed up the
character is
not that we really needed the reminder
considering the guy just spent the whole
movie dressing up like his mom and
stabbing people
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too
you